[Applause]
David
air and it's in theater starting Friday
we have to talk about the actual shoe
like the shoes are amazing I've been a
fan since I was a kid
um so do you remember the first pair of
sneakers that you bought that made you
feel cool because I grew up with no
money
so most of my poor sneakers had like
marks on the floor but the first pair I
bought I just felt like I had it was
like with my first check yeah you bought
on your own and I bought like from my
job I bought and I felt I wore them out
I had the Jordan fours I bought the
Jordan fours I was about the 11th grade
89 and I had to save money working for
my daddy's company took a cleaning
service and yeah because people been
asking me and I had to go back and find
what was that shoes Jordan Force but it
was the energy man like clothes make you
feel good the Jordans make you feel like
you can jump like Jordan and yeah and
that's what this movie got in and you
know people bought back shoes and buy
clothes because it makes them feel good
it's good for your mental state so you
know I'm glad you just said that because
that was the most interesting thing too
that I found there were a lot of I'm
gonna say that about everything
um but I had no idea that the league
only allowed you to wear a certain type
of shoe for a certain time yeah and then
it was like you had to pay a fine I
didn't know that either yeah it had to
be a 51 white I know not allow the shoe
to have I had no idea of that like all
this information that's in there and
then that shoe is revealed and you're
was like it is so magic this film is so
good it's so good I loved it I thought
it was so cool so one of the main themes
of the movie is fighting for your own
self-worth um when do you feel like
you've had to fight for that in your
life I think the act of being an actor
is like a lifelong yeah by the time I
come on this lot I just remember holding
my sides some audition and no you don't
need to do the second scene we've seen
all we need
you know there's a lot of that it's a
soul it kind of it beats you down it's I
love that you talk about that though
because young actors like the younger
actors are probably like they feel
defeated and they see y'all and they're
like God they made a movie and made it
and like you know everything was so
magical and they don't see the listen
everything happens incredibly lucky very
young and still there were probably 500
parts we didn't get easily so many so
many rejections that I mean it's a
helpful thing about having your best
friend do it too because you we used to
call it getting okay thanks like you'd
go into a room and you'd pour your your
heart out for the for a casting director
and a director and they go like okay
thanks and you'd realize I didn't get
the part you know meanwhile you've been
sitting out there for 45 minutes waiting
as the last person was in there and they
come out and they're all laughing and
hugging and oh see you later and you're
like oh that went well and then you're
out in five minutes and you're like and
all you really have is you know we'd go
home we live together with his little
brother you know and and we'd just go
sit there and had it go I got okay
thanks then sorry man they you know the
hell with that you know what I mean they
don't know what they and you kind of a
job interview where you also are like
pouring your heart out and crying too
you know hey why won't you thanks that's
fine are we good okay because I'm
sobbing like the most dramatic moment in
my life and I can go home quite cool
okay thanks yeah what do you feel like
for you like just to what do you feel
like was a moment for you when you were
younger oh man you know I would say you
know a stand-up comedy you know going on
stages you know making sure that you
you're ready and you know you have
audience sometimes you have great shows
sometimes you have lukewarm shows so you
got to go back to the club really
struggle or were you just like hot bang
right yeah I didn't really struggle that
much I was trying to find something
that's the blessing that we had I had
stand up to fall on because when there's
no work in Hollywood we was on the road
every weekend and we got that audience
response so it kept you up kept you
going it is interesting too because the
audience plays such a big role and I
don't know that everybody knows that
like but I think we realized in kova
nobody's doing like drive-in theater
shows and stuff like that where you
don't really get that interaction but
that live or if you've done Live Theater
like that live like interaction you get
like drunk off even sitting in the room
with a movie which as a director is the
only time this movie in particular
because it's funny and it's optimistic
and you know the cash so good you just
like it more with other people around
you laughing I agree too because I
watched it with friends and I was like
it just having that you're you're almost
looking at each other like you're
rooting for like people to win and
you're waiting for them to believe in
them and yeah
um well we're almost out of time but um
I have to ask did you ever get
distracted by Ben's hair in the movie
because I feel like it should have gone
I did but it helped me it helped me and
see where we were in I was like man this
is something right here
like everyone else would know they're
gonna look better about comparison I
mean the windsuit with the glasses
directly document that I did not put on
one piece of clothing I did not see was
warm don't tell me you weren't excited I
still wear this everybody can hear you
coming
she's so good in this movie and a big
shout out to Charlize our costume
designer who crushed it like like this
is all stuff when when Sunny the real
Sunny came to the Set uh with his wife
and and they looked at me and and
Charlize was standing there and they
turned to her and they said and his wife
said did you raid his closet like I was
wearing all stuff and she had just kind
of intuited exactly what he would wear
in fact I think we we have a gift for
you you know oh yeah
somebody's going to materialize
oh look at this I thought that this is
the only thing is you have to wear them
I wish I was like skiing right now this
is incredible
you're welcome just a little this
section yeah
you're welcome America so good I know
you want to be back for a minute with
Daft Punk
they're super cool I'm gonna actually go
out with it fine uh one more time
forbidden
theater is everywhere starting Friday
and look for it coming soon on Prime
video
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]